hey youtubers is Charlie in Teen Wolf is
back for the summer since a lot of you
requested it I'm gonna be doing weekly
videos for season four so I'm not
planning on doing Q&A videos but if you
want me to do bonus videos like it did
for Game of Thrones just let me know be
sure to subscribe to get everything -
it's gonna be a lot of fun this episode
was kind of that limbo state between old
crew when we still had Allison and Isaac
and the new team with Malia and Kira
there's a bunch of new other characters
we haven't met this season and it's
gonna completely change the tone of the
show but we have to have this episode to
bridge the gap it's all about paying off
what happened to Derek at the end of
season 3 the theme of season 4 overall
is can't go back which is interesting
because they actually left Beacon Hills
to go on a Mexican road trip so what I'm
gonna do is my top 5 moments then I'll
do my review and then I'm gonna talk
about how season 4 is going to be
different and why that's a good thing
I'll just give you a big teaser right
now if you like season 1 you're gonna
love season 4 so careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet but here we go number 5 Wolfsbane
gasps dance party the reason they went
to the club was because they found the
werewolf hunters shell casings with the
insignia of that family the Calaveras
they're just another hunter family like
the Argent's they're not really bad or
good they're just Nazis about sticking
to the hunters code so the dance party
was basically there to introduce the new
team as it exists right now you know
just like give him their grand stage
entrance I love that mallya was the one
who had to tell Kira to fit in when
she's like the worst person ever at
fitting in the two of them are still
kind of Outsiders even after spending
most of season 3 trying to help Scott
and Stiles there was a bit of Mallya
cured of shipping in this moment but I
don't think that's going anywhere I
think they were just being fun I think
the show is mostly gonna be pushing
Mallya Stiles and Kira Scott this season
number 4 Teen Wolf recaps in a Jeep this
episode was all about bridging the gap
between the old team of the new teams so
naturally the car ride is used to tell
the story from season 1 through season 3
even the prehistory on how Paul became
the Alpha it was also meant to set up
what Kate is going to be in season 4
she's been one of the craziest villains
that the show has had and she's also
gonna continue to be a really big thing
in season 4 she's not necessarily gonna
be the main villain and I don't think
she's the mysterious benefactor that
we've been teased with in the trailers
but I'll talk about that in a sec all
the recapping was also meant to set up
the idea that once they do get back to
beacon hills they won't be able to
literally go back to the wait
were it's a metaphor for what happened
with Derrick you know the physical
transformation he went through and the
show itself both crystal Reed and Daniel
Sharman asked to leave the show and
anytime a show it loses two major
characters things get a little weird I
don't think the Teen Wolf is gonna
reinvent itself in season four but they
are doing a bit of a soft reset which is
why I think it's gonna feel a lot more
like season one number three
Lydia tests her abilities apparently
killing people and whichever town
they're in in Mexico is a no big deal I
love that nobody made a scream whenever
that guy died no screams no police
sirens this big test just informs what's
gonna be happening with Lydia's
character this season she's gonna be
developing her powers to the point where
she can be way more CSI with the way she
derives clues she'll be like banshees
Sherlock this season and Stiles is gonna
be her Watson she's probably grown more
as a character since season 1 than
anyone else on the show I loved Holland
Roden but season 1 Lydia was pretty
off-putting before her transformation
that's just her hero's journey if you're
not familiar with Joseph Campbell it
just spells out the archetypal hero's
journey from normal person to hero back
to normal person a lot of fiction and
television writers use it to develop
characters Lydia's journey in season
four is just gonna be learning to master
her supernatural abilities and retain
her humanity it's the same thing that's
going on with all the other characters
like Scott learning to be an alpha and
Molly are learning to be human number
two Derek is transformed into young
Derek the Derek we see is his younger
self played by the actor Ian Nelson who
has played young Derek in previous
flashbacks there's a number of giant
questions raised by this including what
is the effect of the dark moon on the
supernatural in general what is the
significance of the Aztec temple
belonging to those where Jaguars and why
was Derek entombed behind a symbol of
their God who was the figure in the bone
armor because it definitely wasn't Kate
she was busy harassing all the people in
the Jeep and how is all this connected
to the benefactor in the Deadpool list
since this episode was all about
following up on the Derek plot
presumably in episode 2 we're gonna
learn about the new characters the
benefactor and the Deadpool list the
Deadpool is both an awesome homage to
the comic-book character Deadpool and
it's a kill list of all the supernatural
creatures living in beacon hills
it's like Teen Wolf is gonna be paying
homage to Death Note this season and
that benefactor will be like the Light
Yagami of the stories so if you like
that animate you
love season four and my number one
moment WTF is Kate it's pretty clear
she's not just a werewolf based on her
taking Derek to the Aztec temple I think
we can assume she's a weird Jaguar I
love the way the show deepens the
mythology every season you know last
year got super crazy with the kitsune
the Oni the Nemeton etc the list just
goes on and on supposedly this season is
supposed to be a bit of a reprieve from
the super dark direction of season 3
they're not just gonna keep making it
more depressing and make us feel awful
every week that's why they're weaving a
lot of familiar things like lacrosse
back into the story so they're headed
back to beacon hills and I think the
benefactor is gonna turn out to be
someone who's using Kate to cause more
chaos because she's supposed to be a big
part of the plot in season 4 I'm pretty
sure she's not that creature with the
bone armor that Scott was fighting that
person was featured in the trailer so
it's probably gonna follow them back as
well and cause a bunch of trouble
between lacrosse games I wouldn't be
surprised if one of the new characters
we haven't met yet as part of a where
Jaguar family that just happened to move
to town but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments below what was your
favorite moment and do you have a
favorite ship yet I know they said that
they're not gonna do a lot of romance
this season but there will be a lot of
funny ship moments I'm actually most
excited to see Scott develop his pack an
alpha has to have a pack and there were
a few spoilers about who would be
joining him but I don't want to say in
this video just in case you don't want
to know if you have heard spoilers
though and you want to comment about it
just use spoiler tags overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus it was a lot of
fun and it's gonna be one of my favorite
summer shows next to Legend of Korra
which is funny because Teen Wolf
actually shares a lot in common with
that show if you've never seen any of
the Avatar series like Last Airbender or
Legend of Korra it revolves around this
idea of the four elements air water
earth fire so each new season of Avatar
is themed after a different element the
opening title scenes of Teen Wolf also
revolve around elements like when we had
the red in the title sequence whenever
Scott was becoming an alpha which is
kind of like the air element during
season two we had water during the
opening titles it's just a fun
observation but maybe the team of people
our avatar fans I don't know in this
tile scene in the season 4 title scene
there's a whole lot of sand which kind
of makes me think it might be earth
based usually the title scenes inform
whatever the season is going to be about
thematically at least so be sure to
write your theories about what you think
season 4
it's gonna be about in the comments so
the other big thing that stood out to me
in the episode you know between this
balancing act of old team versus new
team was also the new characters
relationships with each other their
human relationships not just the funny
ship you know romantic stuff
the writer said that this year is gonna
focus a lot more on the human
relationships as opposed to the craziest
supernatural ones from season 3 that's
why we're going back to a ton of
lacrosse it's where we started in season
1 before Scott and everyone got thrown
into the supernatural world the
difference this season though is that
everyone that's been around since season
one is so much more mature so Scott
Stiles Lydia can be mentors to all these
new freshman characters that are coming
on way better mentors than Derek was to
Tyler and Stiles he was the worst mentor
ever
unless you count Paul so like I said I'm
gonna be doing weekly videos for each
episode of Teen Wolf be sure to
subscribe to get everything
also let me know if you want me to do
bonus mythology videos and I'll start
posting those on Monday mornings so
right now because I don't have any more
Teen Wolf videos for you to watch yet
click here or here to learn about avatar
Legend of Korra it's starting this
Friday it has a lot in common with Teen
Wolf and it's gonna be super fun so be
sure to check it out thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you